SPEAKER: Autoscaling
helps you size up
to handle increased
demand and size down
to avoid paying for resources
that you're not using.
That's not just
limited to your pods.
It can also apply
to the machine side.
Today, we'll talk about
autoscaling infrastructure
with Google Kubernetes Engine
and cover some best practices.
Let's go beyond your GKE bill.
In the last video,
we covered how
autoscaling works and went over
horizontal and vertical pod
autoscaling.
If you haven't seen
it, I definitely
recommend checking
it out, since we'll
look at some additional
ways that you can configure
autoscaling and how
that can help you
with cost optimization.
I'll start by going over the
cluster autoscaler and then
something really cool,
node autoprovisioning.
Then we'll wrap
up with some tips
to use when setting
up your autoscaling.
So if pod autoscalers can
help you resize or add
additional pods, what can you
do with the infrastructure side?
Well, just like the
pod autoscalers,
you can think of the same
horizontal and vertical options
for infrastructure.
This time, we're talking about
changing the number of nodes
or automatically
creating additional node
pools with optimized size.
This is really where the
cloud and Kubernetes work well
together, since the
cloud tends to give you
a lot more flexibility
with your resources.
Let's start with horizontally
adding more nodes, which is
done by the cluster autoscaler.
The cluster autoscaler is
designed to add or remove nodes
based on demand.
But this time,
demand is actually
based on pod scheduling
and requests.
If additional pods aren't able
to be put into the existing
nodes that are running,
the cluster autoscaler
will create a new node, so
that the pods can get placed.
You can and should use the
cluster autoscaler along
with the horizontal or
vertical pod autoscalers.
That way, as you create
more or larger pods,
your infrastructure can
grow alongside them.
It's also important to note
that the cluster autoscaler is
perfect for cost optimization
since it is actually
built to prefer lower costs.
That means that
the autoscaler will
start by trying to
create additional nodes
of the cheapest type and then
move to more expensive node
types if it can't
create the cheaper ones.
Isn't it great when cost
optimization is just
built right in?
Just like the pod autoscaler,
having an appropriate pod
disruption budget is important
for having an effective cluster
autoscaler.
The budget defines the
minimum number of running pods
for your workload.
So when the cluster
autoscaler is removing nodes,
you can ensure that
your workload will still
be running correctly.
Now, there are some pods
that can't be restarted,
which will then block
the cluster autoscaler
from removing a node.
System pods, like Kube-DNS and
pods that use local storage,
are examples of pods that
can't be restarted by default.
For system pods, you can set
a pod disruption budget, which
will allow them to be
rescheduled on another node,
freeing up their original
node to be deleted.
But you may not want to set
a budget for some system pods
that only have one replica,
like metric server,
since restarting them can
cause temporary disruptions.
For pods with local storage, you
can enable a special annotation
called safe to evict to let
the cluster autoscaler know
that they're safe
to be restarted.
If you have any pods that are
supposed to run for a long time
without being restarted, you
might want to move those over
to a separate node
pool, so they don't
block the cluster autoscaler.
There's also a few more
things to think about when
using the cluster autoscaler.
Make sure to figure
out how to read
the cluster autoscaler logs,
so that you can understand
any unexpected actions.
If your workload
can support it, see
if you can use preemptible
VMs, since those
will be prioritized by
the cluster autoscaler
and could save you
a lot of costs.
But don't forget to have
a backup node pool in case
there's any trouble with
creating new preemptibles
when they're needed.
Set your minimum
nodes by figuring out
the minimum capacity needed
to keep your workloads running
without disruption, so you
don't end up with idle nodes.
So the cluster autoscaler
helps add and remove nodes
in response to pods
needing to be rescheduled.
However, GKE specifically
has another feature to scale
vertically called
node autoprovisioning.
Node autoprovisioning
actually adds new node pools
that are sized to meet demand.
Without node autoprovisioning,
the cluster autoscaler
will only be able to create
new nodes in the node pools
that you've specified.
This is perfect for
helping optimize resource
usage for workloads
and other apps
that don't need extreme
scaling since creating
an optimized node pool
might take some more time
than just adding additional
nodes to an existing pool.
It's pretty cool to have node
pools created based on what
best fits your application.
And as long as your apps
support interruptions,
you can save even more
costs by setting your pods
to be preemptible tolerant,
allowing the auto provisioner
to create preemptible
node pools.
A few other things
to keep in mind.
Consider how each
of your autoscalers
will affect your
apps, and make sure
that you spent the time
to configure each of them
properly.
New node pools can
take a bit longer
to be created than simply
adding more pods or nodes,
so you may want to
adjust the metric value
of your horizontal
pod autoscaler
to create additional
pods sooner.
Set minimum and
maximum resource sizes
based on what your apps need, so
that the node auto provisioner
doesn't interfere with
keeping your workload running.
With all four types
of autoscalers
that we've talked about, there's
a lot of configuration options
that you can use to
customize your GKE clusters.
Effective use of
some or all of these
can really maximize
your cost optimization.
But it's also
important to understand
how long it might take
to scale resources,
especially if you're
expecting large spikes.
Let's walk through
what scaling up looks
like when demand increases.
For both horizontal and
vertical pod autoscaling,
they'll respond by adding pods
or resizing pods, depending
on the settings that we talked
about in the last video.
On the infrastructure
side, if there's
room on your existing nodes that
have already deployed your app,
it might be able to
skip pulling the image
and just start running
the application.
If you're working
with a node that
hasn't deployed your application
before, a bit of time
might be added if it needs
to download the container
images before running it.
But if you don't have enough
room on your existing nodes
and you're using
cluster autoscaler,
it could take even longer.
Now it needs to
provision a new node,
set it up, and then download
the image and start up pods.
If the node auto provisioner
is going to create a new node
pool, there will
be even more time
as you provision the
new node pool first
and then go through all the
same steps for the new node.
In order to handle these
different latencies
for autoscaling,
you'll probably want
to overprovision
a little bit, so
that there's less pressure
on your apps when scaling up.
This is really important
for cost optimization
because you don't want
to pay for more resources
than you need.
But you also don't want
your apps to struggle.
Let's go through two strategies
for figuring out how to
over provision using a
pretty simple formula.
We'll start with
a formula you can
use to find an optimized
target for using horizontal pod
autoscaling.
The first thing we'll want is
an appropriate buffer target
for the application to
ensure that everything
is running smoothly.
Let's choose a buffer
size of about 15%,
so that we can keep the
application safely away
from 100% CPU utilization.
Then we can take a look at the
percentage of traffic growth
that we might expect in a
two- to three-minute period.
Here, let's say that we
expect a growth of about 30%.
With these numbers
in the formula,
we can calculate a target for
the horizontal pod autoscaler
around 65%.
This generally means
that we'll be about 35%
over provisioned in order
to appropriately handle
the expected traffic growth
while still minimizing
extra resources.
If you're using larger
nodes and smaller workloads
with consistently less
traffic than requested,
you could consider
over provisioning
a bit less since
there might be room
to go above 100% utilization.
The second strategy
is to use pause pods.
These are low-priority
deployments,
which mean that they could
be removed and then replaced
by high-priority deployments.
Since these pause pods aren't
actually doing anything,
they're basically
just reserving buffer.
When the higher
priority pod needs room,
the pause pod will be
removed and rescheduled
to another node or a new node.
And the higher priority
pod has the room
it needs to be
scheduled quickly.
Using these can help
because node spin up time
can happen without affecting
the high-priority pods.
It's basically like
scaling a little bit
ahead of when you
need to since they'll
be spun up before
they're needed, thanks
to those low-priority pots.
It's a good idea to try and
only use one pause pod per node,
so it's quick to be
rescheduled, the API
isn't overloaded with
even more requests,
and the full node will
be available quickly.
All right, that's a lot to
think about for autoscaling.
And "pause pod" is
really hard to say.
Once again, it's important to
know what your apps can handle
and to optimize around that.
But you can also
optimize your apps.
On the next video, we'll
cover different ways
to do exactly that.
Remember to check out the
link in the description
for the full guide on
GKE cost optimization.